morgen nach madrid
schönen guten morgen nach berlin frau
ministerin schon bevor der gipfel
beginnt also gestern abend nämlich haben
sich die türkei und schweden und
finnland
geeinigt über einen nato beitritt der
beiden wie erleichtert sind sie denn
darüber
sehr weil wir sind in wirklich
schwierigen zeiten eines der ziele des
russischen präsidenten ist ja die
wertegemeinschaft weltweit zu spalten
und auch uns als bündnispartner zu
spalten und jetzt ist das wichtigste
dass wir deutlich machen wir stehen
beieinander wir stehen miteinander
finnland gerade grenz mit einer sehr
sehr langen grenze an russland und
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass finnland
und schweden jetzt beitreten können für
diese beiden länder war das ja auch kein
einfacher prozess die gesellschaften
haben sich bewusst in der vergangenheit
gegen einen nato beitritt entschieden
aber jetzt fürchten sie eben um die
sicherheit ihres landes um die
sicherheit ihrer menschen und deswegen
ist es so wichtig dass sie jetzt auch in
der nato sein können und damit schutz
von uns allen bekommen aber es muss
jedoch auch ärgern dass die türkei die
nordwest wochen lang vor sich her
getrieben hat
ja für sie erleben dass immer auch
unterschiedliche interessen in
unterschiedlichen bündnissen sind aber
das entscheidende ist dass bei der
zentralen frage für demokratie
einzustehen für sicherheit für freiheit
einzustehen dass da alle beieinander
stehen es waren keine einfachen wochen
das muss man deutlich sagen wir hatten
ja ein erstes inoffizielles
außenministerin außenministertreffen in
berlin wo wir eigentlich schon den weg
bereiten wollten für diesen beitritt von
finnland und schweden wir als deutsche
bundesregierung haben deutlich gemacht
es wird auch keine lange übergangszeit
geben dass wenn der antrag gestellt ist
das dann finden und schweden verwundbar
sind es gab da einzelne drohungen auch
aus russland deswegen ist es umso
wichtiger dass jetzt klar und deutlich
ist das für finnland und schweden auch
der gemeinsame nato schutz gilt manche
sprechen ja jetzt auch schon von einer
zeitenwende für die nato was bedeutet
denn dieser beitritt von schweden und
finnland für die nato
die nato wird dadurch stärker wie gesagt
finnland und schweden sind ja sehr sehr
starke liberale demokratie sind eu
partner sind eu mitglieder und wir haben
auch schon in der vergangenheit eng mit
finnland und schweden zusammengearbeitet
sie haben starke eigene armeen weil das
ist ja ein bisschen der punkt wenn man
nicht zur nato mitglied ist oder nicht
in einem verteidigungsbündnis ist dass
man dann selber sehr sehr viel geld in
seine armeen gibt das heißt der beitritt
von finnland und schweden macht auch die
nato stärker sowohl mit blick auf die
verteidigungsfähigkeiten aber eben auch
als gemeinsames bündnis für demokratie
und das internationale recht
zweites großes thema dieses gipfels in
madrid heute ist ja die nato will ihre
schnelle eingreiftruppe von rund 40.000
auf mehr als 300.000 erhöhen allein aus
deutschland sollen 15.000 soldaten und
soldatinnen beteiligt sein das alles ja
um russland abzuschrecken wie sehr
besorgt sie denn diese logik des rest
des wettrüstens
das ist kein wettrüsten weil das ist
nicht so dass wir sagen wir müssen jetzt
massiv aufrüsten sondern wir machen
deutlich wir verteidigen jeden winkel
unseres bündnisgebiet ist vorbei
da nicht groß ein haken davor berg aber
es ist doch eine aufrüstung der nato und
ein ziel ist es doch russland
abzuschrecken
ja es ist das dass wir uns besser
verteidigen müssen wir wollten immer in
frieden mit russland erleben russland
hat nicht nur die ukraine brutal
angegriffen sondern hat die gemeinsame
nato russland grund akte was das
grundverständnis war gemeinsam als
nachbarn in frieden zu leben im wahrsten
sinne des wortes in die luft gesprengt
und deswegen haben wir habe ich auch
mich persönlich dafür eingesetzt dass
wir die so genannte nato ostflanke
versteht verstärken wie sie angesprochen
haben weitere soldatinnen und soldaten
auch ins baltikum schicken weil es da
eben die große große sorge gibt dass man
sich alleine nicht verteidigen kann und
das ist wichtig in diesem moment
zusammenzustehen und wir haben ja hier
beim nato-gipfel eben auch das neue
strategische konzept was wir
verabschieden werden und wir stellen uns
dieser neuen bitteren realität dass wir
uns mit blick auf russland jetzt
verteidigen können müssen wenn dieser
fall eintreten sollte
wir haben aber immer deutlich gemacht
und auch als deutsche bundesregierung
dass wir nicht zb die nato russland
grund akte aufkündigen wir wollen in
frieden leben und deswegen ist ja auch
unser klarer appell in jedem moment kann
russland diesen krieg einstellen können
wir dafür sorgen dass in europa wieder
frieden herrscht und das ist das ziel
der nato frieden in europa gemeinsam zu
sichern nato russland akte da geht es um
die stationierung von truppen bei
inländern die nach 97 beigetreten sind
frau werber lassen sie uns noch kurz auf
dem g7-gipfel schauen der gestern zu
ende gegangen ist viele sprachen jahr
von einem erfolg auf verschiedenen
ebenen aber eines ist ja nicht gelungen
indien und andere wichtige
schwellenländer die teilweise ja auch
eingeladen waren nach ellmau davon zu
überzeugen die sanktionen gegen russland
mitzutragen warum ist das nicht gelungen
ja die zeiten sind alles andere als
einfach das haben wir ja schon nach dem
24 februar erlebt dass länder wie indien
auch bei den vereinten nationen eben
nicht bei der verurteilung des krieges
mitgestimmt haben und daher ist es so
wichtig jetzt nicht aufzugeben bei all
den schwierigkeiten bei all dem dass wir
jetzt die ukraine vor allen dingen
militärisch unterstützen müssen sich
verteidigen zu können ist das wichtigste
im gespräch mit allen ländern auf der
welt darüber zu bleiben wie wollen wir
gemeinsam für eine regelbasierte
internationale ordnung sorgen wie wollen
wir verhindern dass in zukunft wieder
ein größerer ein stärkerer nachbar sein
kleinen nachbarn über feld und deswegen
war es so wichtig dass länder wie indien
dass länder die eben nichts in den
vereinten nationen wie 104 41 andere
länder diesen krieg verurteilt haben für
das internationale recht klar einstehen
dass wir mit ihm im gespräch sind indien
zum beispiel bringt ihm wieder immer
wieder vor und das ist mir wichtig wenn
man mit denjenigen gespräch ist die
nicht alles teilen wie wir die lage
gerade sehen sich zumindest in deren
situation hineinzuversetzen ich sagen
wir sind massiv abhängig von russland
gerade mit blick auf unsere rüstungs
importe mehr als 70 prozent der rüstungs
importe kommt aus russland und deswegen
sind eben diese fragen dieser zeit
wahnsinnig große und schwierige fragen
wie man die abhänge ich kann die wir zum
beispiel im energiebereich hatten wie
man die in anderen bereichen wo andere
länder militärisch abhängig sind von
russland wie man die gemeinsam als
diejenigen länder die an eine
regelbasierte ordnung glauben wie man
die gemeinsam in zukunft lösen können
damit wir weiter frei entscheiden können
und in zukunft nicht erpressbar sind als
diejenigen die für freiheit demokratie
rechtsstaatlichkeit und vor allen dingen
ein sicheres leben der menschen
einstehen berbalk uns läuft die zeit
davon aber eine frage will ich ihnen
kurz noch stellen durch den ukraine
krieg tritt ja vieles in den hintergrund
in sachen klima haben die g7 zwar gerade
das 1,5 grad ziel bekräftigt aber es ist
ja nicht mehr der fokus auch die idee
des klima clubs ist noch sehr vage es
gibt keine konkreten beschlüsse damit
können sie als grüne doch nicht
zufrieden sein oder
beim klimaschutz läuft uns die zeit
davon das erleben wir gerade die haben
ja die wetternachrichten und da hieß es
am wochenende kühlt es etwas ab 31 grad
wir leben mitten in europa was die
klimakrise bedeutet waldbrände
trockenheit in anderen zonen der welt
dramatische folgen nämlich hunger
vertreibung durch die dürre und deswegen
müssen unsere kraftanstrengung beim
klimaschutz weitergehen das bedeutet vor
allen dingen raus aus den fossilen
energien aber das ist genau der moment
ist es sehr sehr schwierig jetzt diese
schwierigkeiten dafür zu nutzen gerade
beim klimaschutz bei erneuerbaren
energien einen riesengroßen sprung zu
machen und dafür werden wir klima
partnerschaften weltweit
abschließen die dafür sorgen dass wir in
zukunft auf sauberen strom aus
erneuerbaren energien umstellen die
bundes außenministerin im zdf
morgenmagazin vor dem nato-gipfel immer
tritt der in wenigen ja in einer halben
stunde beginnt vielen dank anna lena
werbung noch mal drin